here with more from our big borders our
very own bill hammer bill uh the problem
is the bombing is not stopped and the
other problem is the fire is ongoing
three of the six reactors are active and
we don't know the status of the other
three what can you tell us sean good
evening to you i just um i'll just break
down the last 12 hours of this war and
kind of give you a sense of where we are
and i think there's i think there's
really three stories at the moment
uh two of them happening here in the
south one in the north let's go to the
story at the moment and that is that
nuclear power plant is in the town of
inner hodar okay so we're in the
southern part of the country uh this is
the giant massive nipper river that
really cuts the country
into sean this is again this is a flat
country
it's largely um farmland
i mean it must be beautiful during
harvest time but not this time of year
this is inner hodar that sits right on
the nipper river that nuclear plant that
now was in question apparently battles
happening around it uh that is story
number one now why is this taking place
in part because the russian military
came out of crimea
relatively untouched i would argue
and so they made a bee line to the east
but they also went west earlier today
now we have some video that we rolled
earlier this morning i think we've got
to queued up now sean there is a road
that leads into this nuclear power plant
and there are i mean you can see it here
uh we watched it this morning on
america's newsroom i i this is hundreds
is it thousands of people these are
civilians from the nearby town
that are
intending to block the russian military
from moving toward the power plant
it was an extraordinary site these are
people who live there uh so that that's
story number one now here's story number
two and that is what is the russian army
doing where are they successful and
largely been successful in the south so
they come out of crimea they make a bee
line over here this is mary opal now
what's the significance of this town
about a half a million people
um ukrainian controlled the russians
were not able to take it at war eight
years ago
and there is a fierce battle that's been
going on for the last three days where
the russian military firing from the sea
of assaf and also from the land above it
but we don't believe
that town has fallen to the russian
military yet uh that battle continues
over here to the west remember the nipah
river comes down this is kirsan trey was
talking about this
a moment ago
we believe that is the one town in the
country that has fallen to the russian
military thus far the mayor confirmed
that a bit earlier today so now you
start to see the the swath of land that
putin's going after all southern ukraine
trying to get the land bridge from the
territory he took in 2014 and link it
cut off all the access from the black
sea to the rest of the country of
ukraine what would be the target next
and all likelihood it'd be the town of
odessa here in the west a million people
sean one of the top five population
centers in the entire country
uh that could be the target next and
reporting earlier today suggested that
the russian military is moving on that
that might be the case
uh perhaps
nine o'clock four o'clock in the morning
there in in
ukraine and maybe by daylight tomorrow
we have more information on this so
that's happening in story one and story
number two story number three i think is
also significant that's what's happening
in the north you're talking with all of
listening to our defense officials talk
today and trying to get some reporting
on the ground
we believe this is as far as the russian
army has been able to advance from the
north and the northeast and we believe
based on the reporting we're getting
that this effort has been largely
stalled out
jack keane was talking a bit earlier
today about the mix and match of
soldiers that have come in from the
north units that have been taken from
different parts of the country that
never fought before together
have poor communication with each other
and as a result that's being reflected
in their lack of ability to proceed
um
on the on the capital city of kyiv which
is different from the south because you
have units down there that have been
established now for eight years again
going back to 2014
so we'll watch that story here and see
whether or not putin's army can get its
well can get something together in the
north and if they can then we're going
to see some more news probably on this
convoy that hasn't moved either and
here's the center part of keeve and uh
this is the airport we showed you this
uh night or two ago and there's a road
that runs up this way about 40 miles and
that convoy basically has not moved
what's the intent
well putin told macron earlier today
that he still wants to take over the
entire country but to do it he's going
to have to take the capital city and it
is still believed by leading defense
officials that he would circle this town
and probably just bomb the daylights out
of it like we've seen in other parts of
ukraine
and try to get the people to concede
one of the towns that's really just
taken some heat is the town of kharkiv
sean i've talked about this in the
northeast one and a half million people
russian russian-speaking city
just about 20 miles from the the border
with russia here and they pretty much
have this town surrounded it has not
fallen they have not surrendered they
have not capitulated to russia the
russian army but uh
kiev has really
uh they've had a couple of really really
tough days there the other store is
going to develop over time and these
numbers are going to go higher by the
day and that's the number of refugees
that are flooding the rest of europe
we're now about a million what you're
500 half a million poland 133 000 in
hungary romania is 51 000 others what 88
000 there so this number is at a million
and climbing by the day sean so that
that's where we believe we are as of
this hour
all right thank you our very own bill
hamrick very informative as always hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else